countdown to a projected win and
poland's ruling party right-wing
populists and looking forward to a
second term in government
mama pavada dorado she we have reasons
to be happy because despite a strong
front formed against us we managed to
win an old science point that it would
stay like this and if it stays like this
the good change will continue but what
kajinski describes as good change has
polarized his country it may have led to
the highest turnout in any election
since 1989 the law and justice party
does deliver on its promises for example
a $125 a month allowance for parents of
each child and zero tax for under 26
year olds all in this past term it's a
party that does do what it says on the
tin but many people are concerned about
what's deep inside that ting the
opposition says the ruling party is
taking Poland away from western-style
liberal democracy that's it
people want cooperation they want to see
asbury divisions we see in our country
today unfortunately the law and justice
has moved things so radically to the
right that indeed the liberal minded
people don't feel at ease anymore in
Poland one of the doubts in the minds of
some voters is media freedom the state
media is firmly in the grip of the
ruling party and Poland has dropped from
eighth down to 59th in an international
media freedom chart the ruling party is
tied to the Catholic Church more than
other governments and it's vitriolic
about gay rights last summer police
moved in at wrong gathering of the LGBT
community when men attacked it shouting
abuse opposition parties blamed
political rhetoric for stirring up
hatred
[Applause]
the government that's looking set for a
second term promises a brighter future
for Poland many say if they're better
off it doesn't matter whether it's left
centrist or right-wing Andrew Symonds al
Jazeera Wasel